okay welcome to the show so yesterday I
sort of took a break from talking about
impeachment we did talk about Donald
Trump's claim that he would try to use
the Supreme Court to block impeachment
but we got a break from the growing sort
of demands and momentum that keep
building when it comes to the
impeachment of the President of the
United States and at this point in time
is a debate on impeachment in the House
of Representatives even avoidable is my
question to you today because the
momentum and the calls for this are
growing and growing almost hourly and
earlier this week I told you about
Elizabeth Warren saying it's time for
impeachment Kamala Harris saying it's
time for impeachment congressman Elijah
Cummings coming over from well there
needs to be consequences too it's time
for impeachment congresswoman Maxine
Waters Harvard Law Professor Lawrence
tribe and on and on and on and the list
has continued to grow during the week
but most notably what I want to sort of
focus in on today is that the list of
people calling not just for a debate in
the house about the impeachment of
Donald Trump but just calling for
impeachment and removal are increasingly
Republicans which is sort of breaking
new ground in this entire debate number
one president george w bush's former
speechwriter Michael Gerson now says
that quote House leaders who by the way
remember the house leaders are Democrats
at this point in time he says House
leaders should lay the groundwork for
impeachment he wrote an op-ed in the
Washington Post and he says that he's
stepping outside of normal partisanship
that we're seeing or it's Democrats
saying impeach and Republicans saying
obviously we're not going to impeach
he's stepping outside of the normal
partisanship he was george w bush's
republican speechwriter he says this is
outside of the normal sort of political
fundraising status quo where republicans
are supposed to help republicans
continue to keep raising money he says
this is just so important that it's kind
of a fork in the road that will have an
impact for decades adding his voice to
the demands is former Republican
governor of Massachusetts William weld
William weld is you might have heard
mounting a primary challenge
Donald Trump and William weld is not
only of the mind that Trump should be
impeached he is a Republican who is
straight up calling for the resignation
of Donald Trump at this point in time
and where I disagree with William weld
is that in an op-ed that he wrote weld
said the country would be quote better
served with a president like Mike Pence
I don't think that that's true Pence is
a disgusting partisan ideologue with
extremist religious views and in
different ways than Trump is a disaster
for the country Pence would be a
disaster for the country but where I
agree with William weld is that we do
need to put aside the kind of
calculation about who would replace
Trump if Trump resigned or if Trump were
impeached this is a longtime Republican
who was a governor a governor who says
this can't go on this this has to stop
and meanwhile the administration that
told us it would be the most transparent
administration remember Trump told us
that it would be Trump press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders has insisted that
it is the most transparent
administration they have not had a press
briefing in a record it's either 44 or
45 days at this point in time I don't
even know the exact number of days and
during that 40-plus day period during
which there has been no press briefing
we learned from the content of the
Muller report that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders admits to straight-up having
lied during press briefings and so there
are more and more calls for her to quit
or to resign or for someone to fire her
I guess it would be Donald Trump
basically for her to go away one way or
the other and let's talk about the Sarah
Huckabee Sanders thing a little bit I
understand that the job of the press
secretary is to put the best possible
spin on the positions of the President
of the United States there is no press
secretary who has not been deceptive by
omission there is no press secretary who
you
semantics games in order to sort of
distort the practical reality or the
spirit of certain situations
Sarah Huckabee Sanders isn't unique in
that way but the level of dishonesty in
lying by Sarah Huckabee Sanders rises to
something that has not been seen in
recent political times by a press
secretary and more importantly usually
when we say the press secretary lied
they insists they didn't lie they insist
they see the numbers differently than
critics for example the Muller report if
you haven't seen it or you've forgotten
what I'm referring to she testified and
it is in the molar report that yes she
straight-up lied to the press corps
about the positions of FBI agents
regarding the Trump Russia probe she
knew it was a lie she sort of chalked it
up to a verbal slip but verbal slip is
like I've said before oops
instead of saying Mitch McConnell I said
[ __ ] McConnell right it was it was a
slip oops I said Steve douchey Fox News
reporter instead of Steve Doocy that
that's a verbal slip concocting whole
cloth and ascribing a political position
to FBI agents that you claim have called
the White House supporting Donald Trump
when it was just invented whole cloth
that's not a verbal slip right that
that's not a linguistic error that was
made that's called straight-up lying and
it's part of a report from a special
counsel she should resign or be fired or
whatever probably not going to be but it
is absolutely and completely
indefensible and then thirdly in the
midst of all this impeachment talk Sarah
Huckabee Sanders should go talk in the
midst of all this the White House is
completely clamping down on letting
anybody in their administration talk to
authorities or investigators of almost
any kind the White House is refusing to
let Trump advisor Steven Miller testify
before the House Oversight Committee the
chairman of the committee is calling it
massive obstruction Trump is claiming we
don't know why that
Robert Muller quote checked his taxes as
part of the Muller probe so that
anybody's saying they still want to look
at Donald Trump's taxes should just stop
because Muller looked at them and said
everything's fine that's a lie there is
no evidence whatsoever that Robert
Muller checked Trump's taxes Trump's
taxes certainly aren't even mentioned in
the unredacted portions of the Moller
report
it's lies on top of obstruction on top
of lies and the question we should think
about over the weekend since this is the
Friday show going into the weekend is if
this series of events doesn't trigger
consequences for the president and his
administration right like if we decide
this doesn't rise to the level of
requiring consequences what will if this
doesn't trigger some action I'm not even
sure what that action is necessarily are
we saying that presidents are really
immune from consequences no matter what
they do and if that's what we're saying
that can't be what the founding fathers
intended when they framed the parameters
of the United States of America so
that's what I'm going to be thinking
about this weekend we will see between
now and Monday or Tuesday
how this continues to develop whether
more prominent voices say it's time to
at minimum start the debate about
impeachment in the house maybe there's a
determination made to actually file
articles of impeachment
maybe the termination the determination
is made that a censure of the president
is the result but it seems to be getting
to that point in time to at least have
the debate in a formal way on the floor
of the House of Representatives and also
over the weekend and I hope to have data
for you by Monday we will see what
impact yesterday's presidential campaign
announcement by Joe Biden has on the
race within the Democratic Party and
also in hypothetical matchups against
Donald Trump so let me know what you
think about any of this about all of
this about other stuff I'm always
available to you on Twitter at D Pakman
you can also follow the david pakman
show on Twitter for the latest clips
from the show at David Pakman show
follow them both and we will followup
about all of these stories after the
weekend today's episode is sponsored in
part by the BRD Bitcoin wallet whether
you have experience with Bitcoin and
crypto currencies or you've been wanting
to give it a try for the first time BRD
offers the most elegant easy to use
Bitcoin wallet out there it's an app on
Android and iOS lets you trade crypto
currencies store all of your Bitcoin and
crypto on the app totally free send and
receive Bitcoin with the app use a
credit card to purchase cryptocurrency
and it's 100% private and secure
virtually impossible for someone to hack
your account BRD themselves won't even
know your information there are no
logins no passwords you just use your
key to access your Bitcoin and you're
the only one who has access to it it was
the first ever Bitcoin wallet in the iOS
App Store they've been around since 2014
they have more than two million users
BRD is one of the oldest most
established and most trusted Bitcoin
wallets in the industry we recently
interviewed Aaron from the BRD team and
it was a great conversation you should
search our channel for it and check it
out
all BRD wants to do is to make Bitcoin
more accessible and simpler to use for
those who want to use it and that's what
they've accomplished with their super
powerful easy to use app download it
it's perfect for anyone who's just
getting started with Bitcoin just as
good if you already know what you're
doing I've put a link underneath this
video